>> HEARNDEN: So this--this class is called
a participant's view builder. It's the UiBuilder
for the participant panel that you see at
the top of a conversation and you see it implements
UiBuilder. There's a bunch of stuff in there
for styles and it's all GWT stuff. The main
thing I want to point out is the UiBuilder
just has one method which is to output its
HTML string and this here is just outputting
HTML strings. These static methods are just
helper methods to keep the HTML well-formed
but this code here is just spitting out HTML.
And before I continue too much further I just
wanted to point out a recent addition to the
build file in wave protocol. There's a new
target now called waveharness_hosted and when
you run that it fires up a GWT hosted mode
with the URL there. When you run it, it runs
this test page called the Undercurrent Test
Harness, and it's just a wave panel on a page
with a fake wave on it. So, if anyone wants
to help develop features in the wave panel
then this test harness is the best place to
do it. And while that's loading I will resume
the talk. So, a UiBuilder is just an HTML
closure. Now to every UiBuilder, there's another
view implementation called a DomImpl. And
a DomImpl reveals the HTML that a UiBuilder
produces and it reveals it using DOM API.
So these two, the DomImpls and the UiBuilders
collaborate quite closely, they both know
each other's structure, and the reason we
have these two--two different view implementations
will become apparent in the next few slides.
So I'll show you--this is the view builder
that outputs a bunch of HTML. In particular,
there are some parts of the HTML that we care
about, like this particular part here is a
component within the view, which is the element
which participant views get attached. That's
in the view builder in the equivalent DomImpl.
So here is a--this is the DomImpl of the participant
panel treated in terms of DOM elements. And
here we see an accessor for that element that
was identified in that string building process.
I don't have time to go into the details but
you'll--if you start looking at the DomImpls
in view builder you'll see this correspondence
between accesses in the DomImpl and particularly
identified parts in the UiBuilders. What happened?
So from these view implementations, from there
we can build the renderers. So we distinguish
between static renderers that produce views
from live renderers that update views. So
if you're looking in the code, the main renderer
in undercurrent that renders any part of a
conversation is called FullDomWaveRendererImpl.
You can take any part of them all, push it
through this thing and it will produce a view
object. As a cooperating sibling of this renderer
is its live version. And the live renderer
maps changes in the conversation to changes
in the views by attaching to views and updating
them. So this is where the two view implementations
come in. We use the UiBuilders in the static
renderers to build up renderings because it's
the fastest way to do it and then in live
renderer we attached onto existing renderings
using DomImpls. So I'll just briefly show
what this code looks like. So, for example,
this is the live conversation view renderer
and you can see all its contents are handling
conversation events, blips being added, threads
being added, participants being added. So
it's listening to model events and in response
to them it's attaching on to existing views
and updating them. So when a blip gets added
we'd find it's containing threads and attached
to it with the view and put in new views as
a sibling, that's all. The other thing I wanted
to point out is that the live views, sort
of the live renderers, everything is done
behind these abstract view interfaces so that's
all clean separable and testable. So that's
the bulk of the talk. That was all about the
rendering path. The other part that's--were
undercurrent has a unique approach is the
UI control path, which is how we handle browser
events. And like I mentioned we don't used
GWT widgets. GWT widgets are the usual mechanism
for handling events in a GWT application but
GWT widgets are heavyweight, they're expensive,
they require linear setup cost. We want a
constant time setup cost so in undercurrent
there's a single browser event listener at
the top of the panel, or you can put it at
the top of the page if you want, it receives
all the browser events that occur in the panel
and there's a registry of event handlers which
are based on clients. I'll just quickly show
you what clients are. So this is
the test harness, it's now loaded; it's running
just a fake in-memory wave. You can interact
with it, edit reply and do everything. But
if we look at the DOM briefly--I'm not sure
how well this is going to come out. But let's
see, where are we? So this--this HTML tree
here, this is for the rendering of that blip
that's highlighted. You can see that it has
an attribute on it called kind and its value
is B, and that tells you this piece of UI
is a blip. I want to--all the significant
bits of the HTML are annotated with these
kinds, this thing here has kind equals S.
Now, this is the participant's panel. The
values of these things can be anything. We
just keep them short to keep the DOM small.
But it means that as you're looking at the
DOM you can see where all of the objects are.
In particular, this is what we use for event
dispatch. So there's a top-level event handler,
it receives a browser event, it finds the
source of the elem--source of the event, traces
up the DOM, finding the nearest answers to
with the kind and it looks for any event handler
that any feature might have registered for
handling events on that kind and it dispatches
the event that way. Okay. I need two more
things to talk about I'm just going to pay
lip service to these. Undercurrent uses a
staged loading architecture. What this is
designed for is so that from a completely
cold start of visiting--visiting the client
for the first time were you got nothing cached,
you've never used the app before, we were
still aiming for 150, 200 odd milliseconds
startup time. So, the code is all structured
so that you load--you get a static rendering
from the server, some minimal java scripts
gets downloaded which gives you the abilities
to read it and move around in it and then
JavaScript to start editing. That's all delayed
until later and there's a stage pipeline.
The only reason I mentioned it is because
the top-level entry point into the undercurrent
code is dealing with all these stages so the
search is not unfamiliar if you see these
stages. So lastly, this entire architecture
for undercurrent is designed for load latency
startup and the key component that provides
load latency is server-side rendering so that
the HTML that has a rendering of the wave
could embed on the initial download page before
any JavaScript, before the app is even loaded.
So this kind of raises the question, "How
do you render things on the server?" So there's
two levels to doing server-side rendering.
The first one is rendering the contents of
individual documents. And the way we do that
is the editor, which is open source, we just
use the plain old editor but we've run it
in a server environment that fakes out GWT.
This is called GWT JVM. Joseph is the best
person to ask too if you got questions about
GWT JVM. But basically, the editor runs, does
its thing, thinks it's in the GWT application
but this GWT JVM mocks out GWT, saves what
happens and has a--just an in-memory DOM for
it. The next level up which is stitching these
documents together into a wave, while as you
saw undercurrent defines all its renderings
just as plain string functions so there's
no magic here and we just run these functions
on the server just as Java and we get wave
renderings. So anything on these--if you have
a server that runs these things it only needs
to provide a little bit of extra data along
with this rendering. It needs to provide that
ID mapping state that you saw at the start
that maps between the long model IDs and the
short IDs which you can use to figure out
what these view IDs all referring to. It needs
to talk, it needs to inject into rendering
metadata what the version of the wave was
so the client can connect to that version
and it needs some extra metadata if you start
doing fancy stuff like paging or not rendering
all the blips in the server. But the key thing
is this server-side rendering is very fast.
It's at least twice as fast, if not five,
ten times faster than doing this rendering
on the client. It's paralyzable out so that
you're really only limited by the size of
the largest document in the wave. And most
importantly, this rendering could even be
pre-computed. So you can prepare a rendering
while you're indexing waves or respond to
changes so that next time a client request
a wave you can give them the HTML straightaway,
no processing. I should mention--there's no
server-side rendering hooked up in Wave in
a Box yet. It's a key--it's a key part for
a fast client that anyone who wants to get
their hands dirty is more than welcome to
dive in. We're very happy to help you get
started for that. So I just want to finish
up by saying what undercurrent currently has
and what we plan to have in the near future.
So currently, I think in terms of feature
parity with the Google Wave client, all our
rendering stuff is all the same. The rich
content, all the different reply types: inline,
non-inline, private replies, collapse content,
all that, it's all there and it's all live.
In terms of reading, there's a focus frame.
We track read/unread state. There's a small
patch which we're going very soon where once
you read waves in Wave in a Box, next time
you come back all that read state is preserved,
collapsing threads and so on. Editing, you
can edit, reply, delete, you can continue
threads. Continue is grade up because we don't
have a UI for it other than keyboard shortcuts.
There's an edit toolbar gadgets now work and
so it's definitely got some momentum getting
all those features in. The next features that
are coming--there's a few small pieces lurking
through it. Anyone who wants to dive in and,
you know, start working on the wave panel,
these are the kinds of things that are perfect
to get started with. Please come and talk
to me if you're interested. The blue reply
indicators that you see in the wave panel
in Google Wave you can get them hooked up
with a reply box, participants profile cards,
typing carets, there's a bit of polish for
IE, these are all great places to get started.
There's some medium features which we may
or may not get done before the end of the
year, which is to our view port-based rendering
of content which is something that the Google
Wave client does which significantly reduces
startup latency, and your blip counters counting
how many blips are in threads. And large scale
features which the engineers in Google might--we
won't have time to do any of these but if
anyone wants to take on this, this is a big
meaty project, then we can tell you all about
how it works in Google Wave to give you ideas
on how to get started: playback, diff-on-open
and how to write on a rendering server for
server-side rendering. Alright, has anyone
got any questions about any part of what I've
talked about? I know you've all been bamboozled
with plenty of information today. Yes, question?
>> In exactly in ToolBot, is that part--can
you render the blips if you don't render them
as editors in the first place? So I have to
click on edit first, is that by decision or
is it technically slow to make everything
process editable write on that?
>> HEARNDEN: Right. So the question is when
we render blips, we don't render them as editable
things immediately. There's a combination
of efficiency reasons and product reasons.
I guess the main one is the efficiency reason,
this rendering a blip versus attaching an
edit it to it. Rendering is significantly
faster than rendering plus attaching edit
ability. Also from a product standpoint often
like reading is a far more frequent action
than editing so paying a latency cost from
your initial download to get the editor code
just to view content is probably not worth
it. And also, we do have in undercurrent it
does have what we call full wave edit mode,
which is when you're in the edit mode, as
you click around blips you stay in edit mode.
This wasn't the way that the Google Wave client
originally was so I guess the code is kind
of written with that original mindset just
with how the original product respects itself.
Yes, does that answer your question?
>> Yes. You said attaching an editor's expensive,
that's essentially browser backend which is
the--attaching its control editor or is it
the JavaScript [INDISTINCT]?
>> HEARNDEN: No, Google like--yeah, the rich
text editor. If--but we could just set all
the documents into content editable mode but
that wouldn't work too well with the editor.
There's two talks tomorrow on the editor,
I'll be describing some things about content
editable. And, yes, for reasons that will
be explained tomorrow, it wouldn't be beneficial
to do that. So--yes, yes. Okay. No other questions?
Alright, one other question, yes?
>> Do you use local storage--special storage
for anything in the device?
>> HEARNDEN: In undercurrent, no, we don't.
No.
>> [INDISTINCT] is that the client's attributes?
>> HEARNDEN: Yes.
>> Is that from a standard HTML?
>> HEARNDEN: That's true.
>> Thank you.
>> HEARNDEN: Yeah, the question was, is
the client attribute standard HTML,
and no it
is not.
>> You going to [INDISTINCT]?
>> HEARNDEN: Possibly. Like it works in
all browsers right now and if and when it
becomes an issue that it's not well-formed
or anything then, yes, I'm sure we can fix
it
up. Yes. Alright, thanks everyone.
current, no, we don't. No.
>> [INDISTINCT] is
that the client's attributes?
>> HEARNDEN: Yes.
>> Is that from a standard HTML?
>> HEARNDEN: That's true.
>> Thank you.
>> HEARNDEN: Yeah, the question was,
is the client attribute standard HTML, and
no it is not.
>> You going to [INDISTINCT]?
>> HEARNDEN: Possibly. Like it works in
all browsers right now and
if
and when i